assalamualaikum guys before the video
starts i am looking to raise funds
necessary to get a brother die
with a disability a device which will
give him increased access and ability to
his computer
he currently does a lot of work behind
the scenes in terms of video editing
and subtitle works please give in the
link below in charlotte brom sisters
and it's just only 600 pounds we can do
this in matter of seconds
let's help him inshallah and may allah
preserve him
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the qurani
app is about to show you your progress
with your soul yes that's correct not
only does it encourage you to read it
tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah subhanahu wa tala's
book like you've never had before
assalamualaikum brothers assistant
defense we're here with a handsome guy
did you shine your hands as well but
it's a different handsome guy yeah
okay he's got swagger he's he's he's
making it happen yeah so you gotta give
me some lessons on my clothing
uh so yeah it's a little bit windy i
know i'm gonna keep it like this but
we was doing a social experiment today
guys and he came by he just came to say
hello
but he said something profound so you
said that you used to be
do music yeah yeah i used to do music
for like about three years
but um i saw one of your videos about
the me it was me and him we did a video
together yeah i think it was and
it was about chunks quitting music and
it just
really like it just made me feel like
there was something missing in it like i
just felt like
i wasn't i felt like music was kind of
misleading
in a way because you got a lot of people
talking about like drugs and alcohol and
ladies and stuff like that so i was like
it just didn't make me feel i felt
uncomfortable in a way
so i was like you know what this this
ain't for me in it like i gotta get
closer to you know
you know my faith in it so what was it
in particular that made you think you
know what i need to
i need to change this like i said i just
feel like it's
it's it's just like misleading
did it have an impact because you see i
believe music has an impact on your
whole lifestyle
so for example if an al-qaeda said music
and the quran cannot
stay in the same heart yeah one would
override the other so would you say when
you was listening to music
because in jahlil when i used to listen
to music it would impact my lifestyle
i'll be honest with you when i used to
roll with like gangs and stuff like that
i used to listen to certain music before
going to a fight
because they were trying to say it was
intoxicating for me and i never did
drugs so do you think it had that impact
on you in your lifestyle
yeah 100 i would say that like listening
to music
is different to listening to the quran
100 like i feel like the quran when you
listen to it
even in your bad days you just feel
relaxed yeah you feel like
like you can you can do stuff in a sense
you feel like
yeah you just feel light yeah but when
you do music you just feel like
i know some heavy yeah heavy like you
for example i'm not gonna like
drill joe artists for example they they
have like a lot of
negative like why but i think i think
that's one of the reasons why they're
killing each other
i believe he plays a direct role if
you're talking about y'all rolled up on
man
boom boom hundred percent if i'm
listening to that brother i want to do
that if i'm listening to yeah i shot man
i robbed mans i did this in my head i'm
thinking rob shot killed
rock what do you want me to do how can i
be like yeah rob shot killed oh let me
go and save someone's life
yeah it's kind of like brainwashing
people especially the youth
they grow up to you know think like this
kind of stuff is normal in it
and they want to look cool for like
school and stuff it's it's not the way
it's it's absolutely not the way and
easy it needs to do music any i'll ask
questions because we
want to go yeah
now where do you shop man yeah man you
need to take us to it we need to swagger
because you know i'm trying it but you
know but it's not working